face that man
cy young contender garrett cole 28th
start 15-7 2.75 era 224 strikeouts in
163 and two third innings 37 walks he's
given up 19 home runs opponents hit 210
against him
and i think it's time now for the
scouting report
i'm going right at it i mean he looked
healthy and baltimore threw the ball
very well five innings one run on
tuesday so that was the big question and
it is a two horse race at this point in
the season you hate to think about
personal accolades but the cy young will
come down to garrett cole and robbie ray
from toronto so we'll see how both of
them finish the season and looking ahead
all the sudden cold starts are becoming
you know to kind of focus you got today
you've got friday in boston the middle
game in toronto you either pitch him in
the wild card or the 162nd game a lot
can happen but garrett cole is going to
be a big part of it derrick cole is
ready and let's do it here in the bronx
and he gets pumped zimmer could not get
out of the way so he gets hit with an o2
pitch to take first base well i tried to
throw that slider down and in and just
tugged it across and again we've talked
about it when a hitter gets his weight
out on his front foot
a way to get it out of the way but this
ball clearly
got away from garrett cole zimmer's in a
lot of pain top of the calf yeah that
looks actually like a decent place if
you're going to get pick and pick to get
hit with a pitch never a good way to
start off the game as a hitter he's
trying to walk it off
and the indians load the bases for
harold ramirez
harold ramirez swings at the first pitch
at the fairball zimmer scores here comes
jose bobby bradley on his way to third
he'll stop there it's a two-run single
for harold ramirez and the indians
strike for two in the first against
garrett cole how about that this is this
is
incredible hitting them where they ate a
little finesse job with the bat i mean
yeah little q shots coming off one down
the third baseline now this one
he just stays inside the baseball right
over the bag at first base he'll get a
single two runs are gonna score
rizzo can't get there you could not ask
for a better start against cole he
doesn't know what happened hit the first
guy has a walk
and a couple of change-up hits eli
morgan is going to be the indian's
starting pitcher brought to you by your
northeast ohio ford dealers making his
16th start morgan's first start against
the indians he's been much better on the
road this year he's making his seventh
start one-on-one record and a 331 earned
run average dj le mayhew to lead it off
swung on a miss there's good example
elevated the fastball out of the strike
zone and lamehu chased it so eli morgan
with a strikeout to start the bottom of
the first with a two-nothing lead guys
can't catch up to it i don't look at the
velocity it's the location and it's
tardy man because they know in the back
of their minds he's got a good change
anthony rizzo don't show him anything
there's the change up there
off the end of the bat shallow right
harold ramirez two down two outs yankees
batting with the bases empty in the
first swung out on the bouncer to short
knee high hop handled by jimenez and how
about that eli morgan maintains the
momentum with a one two three first
roberto perez as we start the second
inning
grounded softly to second torres is
there he gets perez one away
swing and a miss gets the fastball by
him two-way garrett colt has shown a
good slider and a good fastball there
kind of tailing away there's ernie
clement
clement lifts a fly ball to mid right
underneath giancarlo made the catch and
cole has it one two three here in the
third inning and the banner will be
harold ramirez two on two out big
harrell delivered in the first
this time a fly ball shallow center
field it's dropping gartner to the
rescue makes the catch no ball pops
loose two more are going to score for
cleveland the yankees
avoided a potentially disastrous
collision but the ball ended up dropping
as i thought gardner was going to make a
spectacular play and
maybe it was just the threat of running
into judge
i'll tell you what that's where the
communication there here comes judge
he's diving in gardner's coming in from
the side and they're lucky they didn't
collide it's one of those tweeners
nobody could call for it gardner
with the backhanded side judge coming in
and i'll tell you what another one a
little tweener
off the end of the bet harold now has
four rbis on two hits now roberto perez
with two on and two
looking
out
a line drive single in the center
another run is in as big harold comes
home and it's a five-nothing indians
lead roberto perez with an rbi single up
the gut well the offense has to get
going now they're down five nothing as
they head to the bottom of the third
inning oh two
high fly ball right field and deep
ramirez back on the track at the wall
sia hits the top of the wall and bounds
into the seats and the yankees have a
run on the ursela home run 5-1 indians
they're going out to look at ramirez who
hit that wall
full tilt he thought he had a chance to
make the play but that wall snuck up on
him man knocked the wind out of it more
than anything and that right shoulder
and maybe his head hit the wall as he
goes into it and then comes smack down
on the ground that's it the right
shoulder went smack dab into it that's
what's going to be sore for him his day
is over that's a shame
drive to left coming on mercato diving
attempt he made the catch
oh nice grab by mercado diving headlong
toward the infield and he made the catch
with that ball sinking
just a foot or two above the grass jose
ramirez leads it off for the tribe fifth
innings one and one on the tribe d.h
today
just launched one deep in the right
field and it's gone for jose ramirez
home run number 35 on the year and it's
6-1 cleveland and gareth cole stays on
to work to sixth tribe six new york one
catcher roberto perez
roberto high fly ball deep left field
guard
looking up it is gone to the bullpen
are you kidding me roberto perez going
deep and the indians continue to torture
the yankees here in their home ballpark
for the second game in a row so two out
two one indians up seven to one and
here's you chang
little jam shot center field it's gonna
drop around third scoring is jose
ramirez he has scored his fourth run of
the year
i love it and the indians take advantage
to score another unearned run they lead
eight to one now you gotta face the
mirrors with the bases loaded have a day
jose
and now jose finds a gap in right center
field that's going to get two more home
and it's 10-1 cleveland he was thinking
i don't have enough rbis today i need a
couple more ernie clement
ground weekly hit to first rizzo up with
it bobbles it everybody's safe in to
score is chang and an air on rizzo and
the indians lead 11-1 and glebertore is
the last batter for new york 3-2 pitch
and a miss hey he struck him out to end
the ball game what a way to finish sam
henches strikes out the side and aaron
boone's ball club
absolutely got their tails kicked over
the weekend here in these last two games
by the indians tribe wins it by a final
score today of 11
to 1.